muy bien vamos a hablar de la estructura
microscópica del hueso en particular
vamos a hablar del sistema de hubbert
ahora tomemos un pedazo de hueso y
cortemos lo a la mitad para ver cómo
luce por dentro aquí tenemos una sección
transversal del pedazo de hueso vamos a
ver lo que hay adentro la parte más
interna de este hueso está hecha de lo
que llamamos hueso esponjoso también
conocido como hueso trabecular y podemos
ver que esta flecha señala las trabes q
las del hueso esponjoso por lo que no
nos sorprende que al observar el hueso
esponjoso luzca muy parecido a una
esponja y de hecho debido a que hay
varias trabecular o cavidades en el área
superficial del hueso esponjoso es diez
veces mayor que la de la capa exterior
del hueso compacto básicamente el hueso
esponjoso está compuesto de esta red
porosa de puntas que rodea la parte más
interna de la médula ósea y el efecto
general de esta red esponjosa en el
centro del hueso es hacer que el hueso
sea más ligero sí ahora vemos la
periferia del hueso tenemos la capa más
densa y dura que rodea algo
esponjoso esa parte se llama hueso
compacto y no nos sorprende que el hueso
compacto sea pues más compacto que el
hueso esponjoso tiene menos espacios y
huecos pero lo que realmente hace
diferente al hueso compacto del hueso
esponjoso es que tiene un tipo
específico de organización que está
formado por usted o nas o unidades
funcionales repetidas y aquí tenemos una
vista ampliada de una [ __ ] na y otro
término para estas opciones es sistema
de covers así que hablemos más de este
sistema deja ver cada una de estas
opciones lucen más o menos como un
cilindro que tiene varias capas de hueso
concéntricas o láminas en realidad que
se envuelven entre sí para formar esta
ostión a cada una de estas capas se
llama laminillas y en el centro de estas
capas hay un canal que es el conducto de
javier o canal central por este canal
pasan los vasos sanguíneos los vasos
linfáticos y los nervios también ahora
entre estas capas de laminillas están
estos pequeños canales que se llaman
canal y culos que más o menos podemos
ver aquí
esto surgen del canal central deja bears
hacia estos espacios vacíos y siempre
que vean la palabra la cuna o la cuna o
laguna deben de pensar en espacio vacío
cada una de estas lagunas es solamente
un espacio vacío para los dos trocitos o
células óseas los dos trocitos tienen
estas largas prolongaciones que se
ramifican por los canal y culos para
contactar a otros dos trocitos mediante
uniones en hendidura lo que permite que
estas células se comuniquen entre sí y
puedan intercambiar nutrientes y señales
finalmente los canales de walkman que
son canales que viajan de forma
perpendicular con respecto a los
conductos de hubbert que conectan a las
opciones entre sí y como pueden ver
llevan su propio conjunto de vasos
sanguíneos no olvidemos que la capa
externa superficial del hueso se llama
periostio peri significa alrededor o
rodeando por lo que esta es la capa del
hueso más externa y la que podemos ver a
simple vista